[Musique]
étrangère
réalisons le rêve,
nous avons besoin d'une [ __ ]
d'action à succès,
les gens se demandent si tu as encore été
viré, j'ai peur qu'elle fasse
une autre crise psychotique, c'est beaucoup, c'est
beaucoup, alors donne-leur ce qu'ils aiment, regarde
la caméra et baise tout le monde en
Amérique, baise-les et baise-les bien
Los Angeles est l'endroit où tous les monstres du
monde se réunissent, croyez que personne ne
devrait avoir l'impression que tout le monde perd la
tête, d'où vient-il
[Musique]
laissez les gens profiter des drogues sexuelles et du chaud  les filles,
ok, arrêtez d'essayer de bloquer l'Amérique
[Musique]
allumez le micro, allons-y
[Musique] [
Musique]
[ __ ] de quoi
[Musique]
alors par où devrions-nous commencer
[Applaudissements]